I lost my work and footage again I know
you Bruce on my face but this way you
can pretend I only let anyone enjoy
Gumrah - beautiful
so welcome to back to the Stanley
parable if I open and close the door
five times something's gonna happen
someone told me five you didn't [ __ ]
worry you [ __ ] liars was it really
this story so apparently there's a bunch
of like at office number four three
seven there's a secret button under the
bureau you should try and find it 437
huh all of his co-workers will shut up
yes Stanley I can't go in a meeting room
perhaps he had simply missed a memo one
two two three four
please are you really just doing this
Hey I can't just give these marriages
little effort a measly fine clicks when
there wasn't five clicks you were to
click the door
20 times I would say that's the kind of
effort the warrants recognition well
[ __ ] you I'm gonna do it 20 times for
five challenge accepted by the [ __ ]
what a dick
no no I'm still not feeling it huh
I want this achievement to have meant
something it has to be a a come on Ward
for valiant effort I want to see some
hustle Stanley do you know how much I go
against a willingness to go all the way
no matter what the cost
why don't you go put 20 clicks into door
number for oneself okay now you're just
[ __ ] with me there is no door for one
salmon there is no door for one okay I'm
gonna find that [ __ ] door if it's the
last thing I'll ever do it's our mission
it's our goal there you I 1 2 3 4 5 how
many 10 to 6 so great now go click a few
times on door 4 3 7 what the hell does
this guy want from me the [ __ ] okay 1 2
3 excellent I think we're getting
somewhere now door 4 1 5 let's give it
10 clicks or so what am I doing this
there you are how many click sitting
whine now back to door number 4 3 7 2 1
White's 437 it s having so much fun hope
you're enjoying this hey hey no no no no
he my dog pulls out the power cable with
his mouth he knows I'm recording let's
see how about you click on well I don't
know the copy machine the capping
machine is that the room for one 7 I'm
really feeling it now I think we're
getting somewhere
no don't do it god damn I'm handling two
idiots as one's here sorry you're not an
idiot in here okay now go climb on
employee for 1/9 desk why am i doing I
can't oh yes this is great I'm not
putting it all on the line Stanley I
like that
let's keep it up don't give me a few
clicks on door 4 1 6 my god the
encouragement to do this I never felt so
motivated I pronounced I weren't totally
wrong motivated motivated
we only farted now
dog farts we've almost got it
now the copy machine do that one again
as my favorite ah dog farts man um it's
like [ __ ] don't do nothing okay
you know Stanley five clicks on door for
free laughs you really understand they
[ __ ] yeah that [ __ ] achievement I
earned that [ __ ] this is an achievement
how click on door for her gasps awesome
nothing could hold you back yes I'm very
proud of her don't worry I'm today just
think only a few minutes ago you
believed in achievement was worth five
little clicks really now what were you
thinking I honestly I only came to a set
of two open doors he entered the door on
his left so I just want to explore a
little bit see what other kind of
innings we can get Stanley walked
upstairs to his boss's office so here's
a different ending I remember you go
down and set him up and it takes you to
an elevator I think if I have what the
hell is this I have that dog before it
just doesn't stop get out of my brain
but this family just couldn't do it
nope he considered the possibility of
facing his boss admitting he had left
his post during work hours he might be
fired for that and in such a competitive
economy why had he taken that risk all
because he believed everyone had
vanished his boss would think he was
crazy
sure and then something occurred to stay
what maybe he thought to himself maybe I
am crazy all of my co-workers blinking
mysteriously out of existence in a
single moment for no reason at all none
of it made any logical sense a scenario
Stanley pondered this he began to make
other strange observations like Y
example why couldn't he see his feet
when he looked down why did doors close
automatically behind him wherever he
went
and for that matter these rooms were
starting to look pretty familiar were
they simply repeating no Stanley said to
her this is all too strange this can't
be real now all at last he came to the
conclusion that had been on the tip of
his tongue white just hadn't found the
words for it but I'm dreaming yes
different this is all a dream Oh Stanley
felt to have finally found an answer an
explanation his co-workers weren't
actually gone he wasn't going to lose
his job he wasn't crazy after war my
thing himself
I suppose don't wake up soon I'll have
to go back to my boring real life job
pushing buttons I may as well enjoy this
what I'm still lucid that's what I think
so he imagined himself flying and began
to gently float no no he imagined
himself soaring through space on a
magical star field and it - what the
[ __ ] they leave and Stanley marveled why
don't you think about tetes like any
normal person let's loosen him so lucid
come on Santa helps the strangest
question of them all entered Stan his
head what one he was amazed he hadn't
asked him so sooner what is it why is
there a voice in my head dictating
everything that I'm doing and thought I
was gonna think about the boobs now the
voice was describing itself being
considered by Stanley who found it
particularly strange I'm dreaming about
a voice describing me thinking about how
it's describing my thoughts
II thought ah III wonder this voice
spoke to all people in their dreams the
truth was that of course I defended
dearly how could it be yes Stan is
simply deceiving himself believing that
if he's asleep he doesn't have to take
responsibility for himself
Stanley is guys awake right now but he's
ever been in his life but now hearing
the voice speak these words was quite a
shock to Stanley and what are you doing
stop Tommy he knew for certain beyond a
doubt that this was in fact a dream
night voice not see him Flo to make the
magical stars just a moment ago how else
would the voice explain all that but
this voice was a part of himself too
surely surely if he could just do what
he would prove it wife that he was in
control that this was a dream tetes
tenth texas texas Tesla's gently
uh-huh and he invited himself to wake up
okay he felt the cool weight of the
blanket on his skin
the press of the mattress on his back
you did you the fresh air of a world
outside this one uh-huh let me wake up
he thought to himself cus I'm through
with this dream I wish it to be over let
me go back to my job let me continue
pushing the buttons please it's all I
want I want my apartment and my wife and
my job all I want is my life exactly the
way it's always been my life is normal I
am normal everything will be fine okay
oh they're weird [ __ ] ending it's not
over it wasn't a dream
Stanley began screaming hey someone wake
me up I name is Stanley I have a boss I
have an office I am real please just
someone tell me I am real
and everything went black ah [ __ ] this
is the story of a woman named Mary Ann I
am
Mariella woke up on a day like any other
she Rose got dressed gathered her
belongings and walked to her place of
work but on this particular day her walk
was interrupted by the body of a man who
had stumbled through town talking and
screaming to himself
that's nice soon turned to go call for
an ambulance for just a few brief
moments she considered the strange man
he was obviously crazy this much she
knew everyone knows what crazy people
look like and in that moment she thought
to herself how lucky she was to be
normal I am saying I am in control of my
mind I know what is real and what isn't
it was comfort into thickness and in a
certain way seeing this man made her
feel better but then she remembered the
meeting she had scheduled for that day
the very important people whose
impressions of her would affect her
career and by extension the rest of her
life she had no time for this so it was
only a moment that she stood there
staring down at the body and then she
turned and ran I think that's one of my
favorite endings and that moment and
there at least it's it's it's very
thought-provoking alright let's do some
more a funny ones cuz that one's kind of
a lot of talking stepping into it what
what did I just do
that's I think that's a secret let's see
alright so this house should have an
open door next to my there it is
there it is I'm scared hold my hand
dude it's weird no it's getting okay
what do you know is this hello
loading the hell
uh this looks interesting you are now
leaving what what if I don't want to
okay I can't go back there read the door
what are you doing here
escape pod bay 4 yeah alright escape pod
launch Bay escape heli ambrus is that
all it just made us walk what are we
going what is this
it's like a I'm like a kid at Christmas
what what are you what what happened
hello that was it that was [ __ ] it I
went when I was [ __ ] act this is a
[ __ ] man that was a lame one all of this
[ __ ] off oh yeah escape depress remember
excellent we're going here
let's see what happens although this
passageway had the word escape written
on it
ours was that at the end of this hall
Stanley would meet his violent death
what but but but but our to live the
door behind him was not shut stanley
still had every opportunity to turn
around and get back on track you can't
tell me what it is point stanley was
making a conscious concerted effort to
walk forward and willingly confront his
death damn straight nugget I said I get
nothing else
Yolo [ __ ] oh sure yeah take it
back
what I'm alive we're alive
double five you didn't do it you had one
chance I'm never doing it oh well [ __ ]
my life ah maybe not how was she
murdered
oh no it's this it was inched closer
closer to his demise reflected that his
life had been of no consequence
whatsoever ha ha
Stanley can't see the picture he doesn't
know the real story trapped forever in
his narrow vision the eyebrows and
willingly accepted this violent end to
his brazen Chive come on no one to die
do I do
should I begin the game again no no what
oh yeah well Stanley cried the narrator
as Stanley was led helplessly into the
enormous metal jaws visceral instant
Stanley was obliterated as the Machine
crushed every bone in his body
killing him instantly no what but but
but damn alive hey boxes is so beautiful
Oh what the hell is going in Stanley
Stanley parable and yet it would be just
a few minutes before Stanley would
restart the game back in his office as
alive as ever
what exactly did the narrator think he
was going to accomplish I don't [ __ ]
know when every pass you can walk has
been created for you long in advance
death becomes meaningless that's all
that is the same do you see now do you
see that Stanley was already dead
from the moment he hit start Wow no
patience employee database I think I'm
ready for the exit oh look at these two
how they wish to destroy one another how
they wish to control one another how
they both wish to be free can you see
can you see how much they need one
another I don't know no perhaps not
sometimes these things cannot be seen
yeah I think the girl is right listen to
me what you can still see those two you
can stop the program please no don't
steal what do I do quitters never play
it and what do I do
I'm sorry what I'm not gonna get naked
you sick [ __ ]